complete the table to show equivalent  measurements in feet and inches so they  gave us the measurements in feet and  they want us to figure out how many  inches this number of feet are so we  know that one foot  is equivalent to 12 inches so we can  fill out this first one right over here  twelve inches make up one foot one foot  is twelve inches now what about two feet  well that's just going to be two times  twelve inches twelve inches per foot  times two feet gives us twenty four  inches  well here at 5 feet i have 12 feet  here at 5 feet i have 12 inches per foot  so 5 times 12 is 60  inches  and then finally 10 feet 10 feet times  12 inches per foot gets us to  120 inches